did you clap phenosis during the  pandemic of course everyone did yes so  are you comfortable that they're now  using food banks in order to be able to  survive well I mean I go to my food  banks quite a lot and and ask you know  why is it what what is it what's the  reason why people are there at food  banks and quite often when you when you  go to food banks it will be people  something will have happened you know  something will have broken down either a  relationship or a boiler or anything  they're usually they're in an emergency  situation  um I know there was a lot of focus on  increasing the starting salary for  nurses there was a lot of focus on  making sure that lower paid people in  the nursing profession  um were were also increased but you know  there's no doubt that people are worried  very worried about inflation